[Musique]
quand les pompiers manifeste et ça n'est
pas si souvent ça se voit et surtout ça
s'entend ils étaient près de 200 sonata
mobilisés est plutôt bien équipé pour se
faire entendre dans les rues de la ville
ce que les sapeurs pompiers demandent
d'abord c'est davantage d'effectifs
il leur manque aujourd'hui 25 postes à
déficit humains qui ne permet pas de
réunir en intervention des conditions de
sécurité optimales
quand
vous partez dans un véhicule et que vous
êtes 4 et que c'est pour un feu dans un
hôtel oui et que le deuxième véhicule
vient d'une autre caserne à un quart
d'heure et le troisième véhicule vient
du nom de cazères on a trente minutes
parce qu'il ya personne sur dix ans oui
là c'est clairement ça mais là en danger
l'équipage
et les pompiers et ça met en danger la
population sur le sinistre on n'est pas
capable d'assurer des secours de bonne
qualité un manque d'effectifs qui
coïncide avec une augmentation du nombre
d'interventions 4000 de plus en moins de
dix ans leur revendication les sapeurs
pompiers les ont présentés ce matin au
président du sdiss une délégation a été
reçue au conseil départemental
[Musique]